en el último vídeo estábamos hablando
acerca de los macro estados y dejamos
esta situación donde teníamos digamos
una lata o este cilindro y teníamos un
techo que se podía mover y les llamamos
pistón
de hecho el pistón estaba mantenido
debido a la presión del gas contenido y
además porque aplicamos una presión o
una fuerza desde arriba gracias a una
piedra verdad arriba de la piedra había
vacío así que esencialmente aquí había
una presión aplicada tanto por las
partículas como por el peso de la roca y
bueno si no teníamos ese peso entonces
el techo o el pistón se iba a salir
volando verdad indefinidamente porque no
tendríamos una presión y esto debido al
vacío pero bueno como tenemos esta
fuerza entonces llegábamos a cierto
punto de equilibrio aquí y el hilo
grafica vamos en este diagrama de
presión volumen déjenme ponerlo aquí
como en magenta ese es nuestro estado
uno este estado uno que estoy marcando
aquí y entonces en el último vídeo
simplemente
lavamos la mitad de este bloqueo de esta
piedra la evapora vamos y la fuerza que
se aplicaba se reducía a la mitad verdad
así que el gas lo iba a empujar hacia
arriba y esto ocurría tan rápido que de
repente el gas lo empuja hacia arriba e
inmediatamente empieza a tener una menor
presión debido a que las moléculas
empiezan a aventar hacia arriba el
pistón y él iba a tomar cierto tiempo
esencialmente el gas iba a empujar el
pistón y luego iba a ir oscilando hacia
arriba y hacia abajo un poquito hasta
que llegábamos eventualmente a otro a
otro estado de equilibrio verdad y
tendríamos probablemente una menor
presión definitivamente tendríamos más
volumen pero bueno ya no quiero hablar
mucho más de eso vamos a a bueno tenemos
este nuevo estado 2 verdad y nuestros
macro estados presión y volumen están
definidos en un nuevo equilibrio verdad
así que me pregunte en el último vídeo
era cómo llegamos a este nuevo punto es
decir hay alguna
historia definida que vaya del estado
uno donde la presión y el volumen están
bien definidos porque el sistema está en
equilibrio termodinámica y la respuesta
era que no podíamos encontrar esta
trayectoria porque entre estos dos
estados todo se rompe de verdad tenía
distintas temperaturas en distintos
puntos del sistema podría tener distinta
presión en algunas zonas del cilindro el
volumen y va fluctuando de mont de
momento a otro así que justo de hecho
aquí había escrito fuera del equilibrio
que no podemos definir estas macro
variables o estos macro estados verdad
así que no hay una trayectoria que
podríamos decir que que nos lleve del
estado uno al estado dos así que déjenme
ya que lo borré
tenemos cierto tipo de equilibrio en el
estado 1 movíamos la mitad de la piedra
la presión bajaba y entonces el volumen
aumentaba la temperatura también variaba
verdad pero bueno llegamos a un segundo
punto de equilibrio y estuvo muy bonito
y todo pero no sería agradable que
hubiera alguna otra forma digamos de ir
del punto 1 del estado 1 al estado 2 que
pudiéramos desarrollar un experimento
pequeño con la roca de alguna forma
distinta de tal suerte que todo esto no
ocurriera y quizás en cada punto entre
estos dos estados
estuvieran bien definidas nuestras dos
macro estados verdad y recuerden lo que
son las macro variables son los macro
estados que son presión temperatura y
volumen hay otros pero bueno solo estos
están los estoy definiendo en términos
del equilibrio termodinámico verdad y
eso significa que hemos llegado a un
punto de estabilidad por ejemplo que la
temperatura es constante a lo largo de
todo el sistema verdad no es no es
constante si por ejemplo a lo mejor en
esta sección de amarillo o que está
tienen temperaturas distintas verdad
entonces es distinta la temperatura en
distintos puntos entonces no está bien
bien definido lo mismo para la presión o
el volumen porque el volumen también
podría estar fluctuando verdad pero si
se desarrollara digamos el mismo
experimento digamos el mismo proceso
déjenme déjenme dibujarlo otra vez tengo
mi cilindro
y en vez de empezar con una roca o una
roca grande déjenme déjenme dibujar aquí
mi pistón justo hasta arriba de este
digamos de este techo móvil del de la
lata y tenemos nuestro gas ahí dentro y
además qué pasaría si en vez de empezar
con una roca pesada digamos que pongo un
buen de granitos o de no sé canicas o
que sea quizás del mismo material de la
misma roca ok de la misma cantidad pero
distribuido como en pedacitos super
super super chiquitos digamos en
granitos de arena
y en vez de desaparecer de la nada la
mitad de esta arena digamos como hice
con la roca y el que hace que
inmediatamente se cambia el estado uno
empiece a fluctuar y estemos en un
estado de no equilibrio en vez de eso
déjenme ir quitando poco a poco esto es
digamos un granito de arena en cada
momento sale entonces si quito un
granito de arena
y después digamos si si tomo un una
cantidad de peso infinitesimal entonces
este pistón se va a mover casi nada no
déjenme copiar y pegar
ok entonces ahora ahora si quitamos un
granito de arena ok
va a ser tantito menos pesado entonces
la presión se va a mover muy poco y mi
pistón vamos a ver cómo se ve esto se
habrá movido de gm de borrar esta parte
y se moverá un un line un infinitésimo y
eso significa una cantidad infinitamente
pequeña verdad
quizás se movió tantito y entonces no
tendríamos este cambio tan brusco en el
sistema que tuvimos en la vez pasada por
supuesto aquí al quitar un granito de
arena estrictamente pues si genera unos
cambios muy bruscos en algún sentido
pero pero quiero que se entienda la idea
de que quitamos un peso muy pequeño así
que la presión simplemente se movió muy
poco un infinitésimo de digamos y aquí
la clave para tratar de hacer este tipo
de incrementos es que en este sistema es
mucho muy cerca al equilibrio este nuevo
sistema es verdad justamente de haber
quitado después un granito de arena
alcanzamos casi inmediatamente el
equilibrio verdad todo lo que estábamos
haciendo
de hecho lo vamos a repetirlo una y otra
vez vamos a seguir dibujando esto
digamos que removemos otro granito de
arena baja y este este granito es
infinitamente pequeño ahora nuestro
pistón se va a mover tantito hacia
arriba ok recuerden que solo estamos
quitando un granito de arena
y después mi volumen del gas incrementa
también un poquito la presión baja un
poco y nos hemos movido a este punto
digamos lo que estoy haciendo aquí es es
hacer algo llamado como un proceso cuasi
estático
cuasi estático
un proceso cuasi estático y la razón de
esto es porque es prácticamente estático
verdad casi estoy en el equilibrio todo
el tiempo cada vez que quito un granito
de arena simplemente muevo el equilibrio
un poquito y obviamente moviendo el
granito de arena en la vida real incluso
este granito de arena que vamos quitando
provoca oscilaciones en el sistema como
en el caso anterior pero es muy pequeño
verdad así que déjenme tomar un granito
de arena cada vez más pequeño y de forma
más lenta para imaginarnos al menos
teóricamente que si hiciera esto en
pequeños o infinitésimo los granos de
arena esto simplemente se va moviendo de
forma continua del punto 1 al punto 2 y
nos gusta pensar esto teóricamente
porque nos permite describir una
trayectoria recuerden porque estoy
siendo tan cuidadoso aquí porque
queremos asegurarnos que los estados los
macro estados del sistema están
definidos en el equilibrio verdad porque
solo están definidas digamos en él como
la presión o el volumen o la temperatura
solo en el equilibrio y si hacemos este
proceso super lento y en
incrementos pequeños esto me permite
mantener la presión y el volumen y la de
hecho la temperatura como macro estados
en cualquier punto del tiempo y poder
graficar una trayectoria verdad una
trayectoria que conecta el estado uno al
estado 2
en este diagrama presión volumen y
podrías decir oye todo esto es como no
sé todo esto a lo mejor puede parecerte
confuso verdad incluso verás que mucha
gente en los círculos de la
termodinámica o en tu libro incluso te
dice que tiene que ser un proceso casi
estático y siempre me he preguntado por
qué la gente se mata pensando en este
tipo de esquemas quitando granitos de
arena cuando simplemente el punto es
mantener el equilibrio baja moviéndose
de tal suerte que tu presión y el
volumen estén definidas en cualquier
momento las realidades nunca vas a tener
un proceso continuo no están definidos
así así están definidos para incrementos
muy muy pequeños verdad donde si estás
en un equilibrio y no estás contento ahí
bueno puedes moverte muy poquito a
través de pasos realmente pequeños y vas
moviendo el equilibrio y esto ocurre
porque estamos diciendo que es estático
verdad estamos diciendo que estamos en
equilibrio sin embargo este equilibrio
se va moviendo a lo largo del tiempo
y esto pasa porque estamos quitando
pedacitos de arena que no estamos
quitando todo sólo una pequeña emoción
una pequeña cantidad de esto entonces
esto ya no entra en un proceso de flujo
y de movimiento raro solo se mueve
lentamente esta es la razón por la cual
estoy haciendo incluso este ejercicio
porque es la clave cuando estamos
hablando de termodinámica y este
diagrama de presión volumen y cuando
estamos viendo otros temas que somos
capaces al menos teóricamente de
describir la trayectoria que toma este
diagrama y no lo haría no no sería
posible si no estuviéramos trabajando
con procesos cuasi estáticos ahora hay
otro término que quizás escuches en
termodinámica y que realmente bueno no
sé yo he tenido problemas para
entenderlo pero es en los procesos
reversibles y a veces estos términos
cuasi estáticos y reversibles se usan en
distinguida mente pero hay una gran
diferencia los procesos cuasi estáticos
o bueno al menos los procesos
reversibles son cuasi estáticos y
de los procesos cuasi estáticos son
reversibles pero no todos la idea de un
proceso reversible es que esto ocurre de
forma digamos si yo estoy quitando
granitos de arena de esto si no hay
fricción bueno yo sé que el pistón se va
moviendo hacia arriba
ok digamos si esto fuera de metal no
esté aquí digamos si no hay fricción
entonces no hay pérdida de energía y
entonces
en un proceso reversible estamos
suponiendo justamente que no hay
fricción y cualquier cosa que ocurre en
el sistema digamos del sistema del punto
a al b ajá digamos si vamos del a al b
con un cambio infinitesimal mente
pequeño en nuestros nuestros macro
estados están bien definidos y más aún
cuando movemos de un estado a otro no
hay pérdida o disipación de energía así
que son dos características muy
importantes por lo siguiente
remarcó primero son cambios
infinitamente pequeños y no hay pérdida
de energía la razón de esto es porque si
estuviéramos ahora en el estado ve y que
y agregamos un granito de arena ok si
agregamos un granito de arena entonces
este pistón baja infinitamente
de una forma infinitamente pequeña y
regresamos al estado a por eso es
reversible verdad porque podemos estar
en este punto de aquí y digamos ponemos
a arena y entonces nos pasamos a este
estado y después podemos regresar este
proceso verdad ahora la realidad es que
en el mundo no hay no hay procesos
reversibles verdad porque siempre vamos
hagamos lo que hagamos siempre va a
haber alguna energía o calor que se
pierde en el proceso así que en el mundo
real si yo me voy moviendo de aquí de
este punto a otros si yo regreso arena
digamos al cilindro voy a perder energía
eventualmente baja lo importante en este
vídeo es que en esta situación que he
descrito que no había un macro estado
intermedio porque el sistema está en
flujo y no está en equilibrio así que si
quisiéramos estados intermedios tenemos
que hacer este proceso muy lento verdad
y cuando digo lento es al menos
teóricamente para poder aproximarnos a
ello pero la idea de la arena nos da una
gran idea de cómo se comporta este
diagrama de presión volumen y que
podemos definir el estado a lo largo del
tiempo cualquier estado a lo largo del
tiempo por eso es que los llamamos cuasi
estáticos verdad porque es casi estático
y está en equilibrio nuestra presión y
el volumen y la temperatura se pueden
definir y si agregamos a eso la noción
de que no hemos perdido calor cuando
estamos cambiando nos de dirección
entonces podemos decir que reversible
porque digamos si quite arena ahora
podemos agregarlo y regresar al estado
anterior ahora con esto dicho voy a
hacer un ejemplo de algo que es cuasi
estático bueno me lo voy a guardar para
el próximo vídeo espero que hayan
entendido estos dos conceptos que vamos
a utilizar constantemente y espero que
esto ya les haya clarificado los
conceptos esto lo voy a mencionar un
poquito más porque cuando lo leí por
primera vez dije cuál es el gran detalle
esto nos permite definir los macro
estados entre cualquier par de estados
que digamos tengamos en equilibrio justo
como vimos en el caso anterior interior
que no era un proceso cuasi estático
porque no sabíamos qué pasaba en medio